oui bonjour à tous pour notre ami
honnête en provence nous avons une
application directe citoyens qui marche
mais extrêmement bien vous l'utilisez il
faut la faire relayer
c'est aussi une façon pour nous
d'alimenter le projet d'avoir une
interaction réel parce que vous pouvez
vous même susciter des questions et
c'est des choses qui vont de plus en
plus vous est proposé de susciter des
questions vous voyez qu'on a un parti en
interaction on n'est pas ascendant
descendant mais on est bien dans cette
réelle interaction et donc vos
fédérations puisque vous avez quelques
compétences vous pouvez tout à fait vous
également faire en sorte d'avoir cette
interaction positive puis les
conférences téléphoniques les
dispositifs qui nous permettent de nous
rapprocher sans avoir à payer des frais
de déplacements qui sont chères et
onéreux et auquel fait en font attention
à notre chère trésorier voilà c'est dit
c'est vous dire est que citoyen c'est un
outil formidable faites le connaître
autour de vous et faites en sorte qu'il
soit encore davantage utilisé